soir près de milan un gaz toxique a
peut-être tué une jeune femme à ces
réseaux le 10 juillet un accident dans
une usine une cuiv explose un gaz
s'échappent pendant quelques jours les
autorités italiennes ne s'inquiète pas
trop banal incident de pollution puis
subitement hier on évacue deux villages
la zone et il faisait et isolée par
l'armée et on recommande à la population
de ne plus concevoir d'enfant
cette fois ci ne s'agit pas de poissons
morts dans les rivières la pollution
s'attaque à l'homme directement
cela remet italiennes sont venus faire
évacuer deux villages attention zone
infestée
et toute cette zone a été isolée par des
clôtures l'accident s'est produit le 20
juillet dans une usine chimique
une réaction que l'on contrôle mal quand
on en a bien contrôlé mille la
température soudain monter une cuve de
2000 litres explose libérant un nuage de
tricks l'euro phénol aujourd'hui deux
semaines plus tard les ouvriers qui
fabriquent est dans cette usine d
essence et parfums des cosmétiques des
désherbants ont dû partir le village est
vide
moore reconnaît aujourd'hui que le gaz
libéré étaient toxiques dangereux le
produit que nous produisons n'était pas
terriblement toxiques 7l triclores
phénol tous avaient encore fabricant
tricolore phénol il pouvait y avoir
certains dangers de d'impuretés qui elle
pouvait toxiques c'est celle là qu'il
fallait surveiller ça nous l'avons fait
nous pose un problème qu'ils ont un pays
comme l'italie
vous avez une énorme industrie chimique
qui est celui des dangers de l'industrie
chimique
précisément c'est tout le problème de
l'industrie chimique qui doit être revue
maintenant c'est trop tard et il faut
vacciner à titre préventif car on ne
peut dire avec précision quels seront
les effets à long terme de ce gaz dans
la composition est voisine de celle des
défoliants utilisé durant la guerre du
vietnam les autorités sanitaires sont
inquiètes et on les comprend
en 15 jours les feuilles des arbres ou
si des animaux sont morts
on se demande même si les rivières
avoisinantes ne sont pas polluées
pourtant les scientifiques restent
prudents il va falloir faire des
analyses pour l'instant ils
s'interrogent ils utilisés en effet un
produit qui est relativement peu
dangereux qui certes peut être irritant
et peut donner des troubles cutanés ou
peut donner des bronchites par exemple
en cas de concentration très importante
et on ne sait pas si ça a été le cas ou
non en italie en attendant de connaître
réellement la concentration de gaz
toxiques inhalé par les hommes
on a donc fait évacuer la population
mais l'affairé reste mystérieuse
pourquoi les suisses puisque la société
i suisse dont il pas fabriquer ce gaz
chez eux
avait-on dit clairement que ce gaz
pouvait entraîner des malformations chez
les enfants
pourquoi tous les produits fabriqués
etait-il envoyé aux états unis en suisse
on s'interroge
et bien ici à genève la firme givaudan
qui contrôle les usines italiennes et
qui appartient à l'important groupe
multinational
hoffmann-la roche approuve les mesures
prises par l'italie
les cultures leur destruction est
indispensable il ne faudra pas les
brûler mais les enfermer dans les faces
hermétique les victimes et bien
malheureusement il pourrait y en avoir
d'autres les symptômes du mal
apparaissent souvent après trois ou
quatre semaines
la substance incriminée elle est
utilisée on l'a dit dans des produits
pour les soins corporels sa préparation
s'arrête à un stade de celle du
défoliant or ce stade aurait été
franchie voilà pourquoi on annonce en
italie la venue d'experts américains
militaires qui doivent tenter de
maîtriser ce gaz qui aurait été utilisée
au vietnam mais le président de la
région lombarde golf hardy veut lui
demander à rome des éclaircissements sur
je cite les activités mystérieuse de
l'entreprise responsable qui fabrique
des produits suspecte et les exporte
intégralement vers les états unis
fin de citation à ces accusations la à
genève ce soir pas de réponse
il ya eu tellement d'exagération autour
des accidents écologiques ces derniers
temps qu'on se méfie toujours un peu sa
part toujours de bons sentiments mais
les faits ne sont pas toujours vérifiée
mais dans cette région de l'italie dans
la banlieue de milan industriels et très
peuplée
une évacuation accidentels de produits
chimiques qui se sont avéré ensuite très
dangereux n'ont pas seulement mis en
émoi toute une population
après avoir beaucoup attendu les
autorités du pays ont quand même décidé
l'évacuation d'un village est de même de
deux villages dont le plus important
celui de meta et on ne sait pas
maintenant ce qui va arriver
un nuage de gaz toxique s'est abattue
sur la région samedi dernier il a fallu
plusieurs jours pour savoir qu'il
s'agissait de dioxine un produit très
dangereux et non seulement on a évacué
mon on parle maintenant de labour et où
le sol comme si on ne s'était pas aperçu
plutôt du danger que le produit
représente et on ne sait toujours pas ce
qui va se passer dans les jours les mois
et même les années qui viennent
michel chevalet ce dont on est certain
aujourd'hui c'est qu'à 15 km de milan a
meta dans cette usine de la société
italienne
icm et sa filiale du groupe suisse
hoffmann la roche un terrible nuage de
gaz s'était échappé samedi dernier il
s'agit du tcd des autrement dit du
tétrachloroéthylène zoo par radio oxy
naples et plus simplement dioxine
précisons tout de suite qu'on ne
fabrique plus de dioxine en france mais
cette substance est connu des chimistes
puisqu'on la trouve à l' état d'impureté
de traces infinitésimales dans une autre
substance chimique le 2 4 5 t un
débroussaillant comment les choses se
sont elles passées samedi dernier en
fabriquant du trick l'euro phénol une
opération classique mais délicate
une réaction chimique s'est emballé la
température s'est brusquement élevé et
la terrible dioxine ses formes
cela a été la première erreur
la deuxième c'est que le dispositif de
sécurité de l'installation n'a pas
fonctionné et que 2 kilos de ce gaz ont
été relâchées dans l'atmosphère et le
résultat vous me voyez
la dioxine est en effet une substance
redoutable à forte dose elle entraîne
une paralysie du système nerveux qui est
mortelle à faibles doses seulement 10
millionième de gramme pour un adulte
elle entraîne des malformations du
foetus entre le 6e et le 15e jour de la
gestation et ses effets retardateurs ont
été mis en évidence sur les reins c'est
là la grande inconnue qui plane sur les
suites de cette pollution
car le drame dans cette affaire c'est
que l'on ne voit pas comment neutraliser
la substance
depuis samedi il a plu sur milan le gaz
a disparu lavé par les pluies et toutes
les plantes tous les animaux contaminés
vont périr mais le plus grave c'est que
ces eaux vont s'infiltrer dans le
sous-sol est pollué les nappes
souterraines non seulement un méta mais
dans toute la région de milan les
autorités italiennes qui ont sous-estimé
la gravité du problème au départ
envisage purement et simplement de
décaper au bulldozer tout le sous sol de
la région
c'est une opération de la dernière
chance en résulte est incertain pour un
travail colossal puisque cela revient à
ramasser 6000 tonnes de terre d'autres
ne sera d'ailleurs plus quoi faire
à quelques kilomètres de seveso où on
envisage d'évacuer les habitants d'un
quatrième village meda attaqué par le
nuage toxique la route reliant meda à
l'autoroute milan comme a été bloqué
pour isoler la zone contaminée
le gouvernement italien a décidé hier
d'autoriser l'avortement des femmes
enceintes touché par le produit échappé
d'une usine de seveso
alors que la loi l'interdît mais il
semble qu'en france la sphère et été
grossis peut-être tout simplement parce
que pour la première fois on a pris
conscience des risques concrets de la
pollution mais sur place
la vision est différente et l'on est
loin de la peur panique des cris de sel
au delà de ce barrage militaire il est
totalement interdit de passer d'ailleurs
les 300 habitants de cette zone ont été
évacuées par précaution car on ne sait
toujours pas un mois après si le nuage
de gaz qui a été lâché par l' usine
digues mais ça tout proche et toxiques
pour l'homme
en revanche on était absolument certain
que la dioxine qui est un composant
chimique découvert dans ses champs est
mortel pour l'animal en effet un gramme
de toxines suffit à tuer milton de rats
voilà l'étendue du problème problème
d'autant plus grave qu aujourd'hui
encore les scientifiques ne savent pas
très bien maîtrisé les réactions
obtenues avec ce produit
ce qui explique l'accident très grave de
lusine 2000 les champs autour de lusine
sont touchés entouré de barbelés mais on
ne sait pas la quantité la composition
exacte du produit qui s'est répandu ici
l'usiné bien sûr fermer les ouvriers au
chômage et des experts tentent de cerner
le mal qui ronge la région plusieurs
fois par jour ont fait des prélèvements
dans la zone contaminée des prélèvements
matérialisé par ce piqué rouge et blanc
que la police locale emmène à milan dans
les laboratoires d'analysés pour
l'instant aucun habitant n'est mort très
peu sont dans les hôpitaux
la seule véritable crainte des
spécialistes concerne les femmes
enceintes d'un ou deux - le gouvernement
italien
les ont autorisés à avorter les médecins
eux sont beaucoup plus réservés
non il s'est bien moqué tu penses au
nord-est a délié fait tsi à montanes
gêner le produit dangereux qui ne peut
entraîner soit des mutations soit des
malformations causés par des substances
semblable à la dioxine conséquent il
peut y avoir danger pour la santé
surtout la santé du nouveau né
c'est pourquoi nous faisons des
contrôles sérieux serait enceinte
dans les premiers seront seulement les
analyses de laboratoire et les
gynécologues qui diront s'il est
conseillé aux femmes les travaux cela
dépend aussi des sentiments religieux
des cno vision profonde que la femme
d'avoir la donne a mis à part les 300
personnes qui ont été évacuées au sud de
milan les habitants de cette zone sont
restés chez eux
pas de panique excessive des autorités
locales ordonne cependant de ne pas
toucher aux produits de la terre
interdiction de nourrir le bétail avec
l'ère deschamps contaminés et ce pendant
une période encore indéterminée
si on ne peut pas toucher ni aux fruits
n'a la verdure dit cet habitant de
seveso
pourquoi vient on le sait pas on sait
pas si c'est dangereux
personne ne nous a rien à une échelle
beaucoup moins importante bien sûr le
phénomène de contamination de cette
région est le même que celui observé au
vietnam
car le produit la dioxine lâché par
l'usiné italienne et celui mis dans les
défoliants employés par les américains
en asie
en tout cas ce qui est véritablement
scandaleux
criminel c'est que les dirigeants de
l'usiné italienne n'était pas totalement
maîtres des substances chimiques qui
l'employait de plus l'usiné en question
appartient à un groupe suisse qui
préfèrent faire manipuler ces substances
dangereuses hors de chez eux et par de
la main d'oeuvre à bon marché
l'accident de lusine italienne n'est pas
encore réglé loin de là et les accidents
semblables pourront se reproduire
partout en europe où une législation
draconienne protégeant l'espèce ne sera
pas en vigueur
la catastrophe de seveso en italie n'a
pas fini de faire parler d'elle car on
s'est aperçu depuis quelques semaines
que les conséquences les plus graves
c'était en fin de compte celle du long
terme imaginez en effet l' angoisse de
ces femmes qui attendent un bébé et qui
savent que le nuage de dioxine qui s'est
échappé d'une usine chimique peut mettre
la vie de l'enfant qu'elle porte en
danger ou en tout cas le rendre
profondément anormal imaginez leur
angoisse dans un pays où l'avortement
est éminemment blâmable bien sûr il est
toléré dans la région de seveso
mais dans ce pays catholique où la
tradition l'emportent sur la science et
le coeur sur la raison l'avortement qui
pourrait paraître à ces femmes comme la
solution c'est en fait une angoisse
supplémentaires
cette femme habite à 30 mètres de la
zone la plus contaminés par la dioxine
elle attend un enfant elle a lu les
journaux elle a regardé la télévision
elle sait maintenant que sous les feux
de la dioxine elle peut accoucher d'un
enfant malformé handicap est anormal si
même je dois effectivement donné
naissance à un enfant anormal
moi je le garde ça veut dire que ce doit
être assise je suis convaincu de ces
choses là je ne suis pas d'accord avec
ce qu'on lit dans les journaux
avec toutes les choses qui ont été dites
dans cette situation tragique et sans
précédent on se demande si le courage
cela consiste à accepter ou à refuser
l'avortement du moins toute femme
enceinte de la zone de seveso ne peut
plus douter des dangers de la dioxine
comme dans le cas de la thalidomide on
pourra voir naître des enfants sans bras
sans yeux avec des organes auditifs
défectueux etc
disons qu'il y à un certain pourcentage
de risque
déjà en temps normal sur 100
accouchements deux ou trois enfants
peuvent présenter des altérations nous
nous avons la certitude basé sur toute
une littérature scientifique et sur
l'expérience du viêtnam que ce
pourcentage augmentera nous ne savons
pas dans quelles proportions
mais ce pourcentage augmentera sûrement
à seveso adhésion dans toute la zone
contaminée
on a ouvert des centres de consultation
pour les femmes enceintes
il s'agit bel et bien de s'informer sur
l'avortement même si la loi italienne le
condamne et le punit les femmes vivent
ici pour demander au médecin d'évaluer
de préciser le risque qu'elles ont donné
naissance à un enfant anormal
mais cette évaluation n'est pas possible
il est clair dans ces conditions que les
femmes qui décident de ne pas courir le
risque et qui par conséquent veulent
subir un avortement se trouve devant un
problème particulièrement douloureux
elle décide d'avorter
non pas en étant certaine que leur
enfant sera normal mais à partir d'un
doute
notre tâche consiste dans ce centre de
consultation a donné le plus
d'informations possibles et à prendre
acte de la décision de la femme à partir
du moment où une femme a pris la
décision d'avorter
que se passe-t-il car enfin en italie
l'avortement n'est autorisé que dans le
cas où l'accouchement présentent un
danger pour la santé physique ou
psychique de la mère
or dans le cas de la dioxine il ne
s'agit pas de la mère et de l'enfant qui
risque d'être anormal
des situations la question c'est pas une
question scientifique par une question
clinique et thérapeutique que mais cette
question un mouvement politique et nous
désirons qui lie à pourra même en italie
une loire qui le parlement il doit
discuter élaborer une loi qu'est qui
permettre à la femme d'un avortement
livrent leur temps parce que je fais
comme médecin une précision et jeudi qui
est là la vente la grossesse chez les
pages une maladie ce n'est pas une
conséquence du neuf jeunes hommes
phénomène effectivement les oblasts x
est la conséquence d'une inaction
physiologique et alors là le mécène ne
peut pas être le juge d'une situation
qui n'est pas pathologique rue mais dans
le cas de la dioxine vous pouvez quand
même jugé s'il ya un visage d'un même
dans l'avenir si mon à mon étude un
événement spécialisation i nostri
gynécologie chirurgie nebe ne peuvent
pas faire des considérations techniques
les médecins ne veulent pas décider à la
place de la mère ils ne veulent pas non
plus donner bonne conscience à l'état
qui n'a pas réglementé l'avortement même
à seveso
et puis il faut bien constater que pour
150 femmes enceintes de la zone
contaminée
il n'y a eu puis quinzaine d'avortement
il y a la peur l'angoissé mais il ya
aussi les convictions religieuses très
forte dans cette région et il aime
donner une des poules il est évident que
toute cette affaire a été montée
il faut bien le dire par une certaine
presse qui a cherché à faire pression
sur l'opinion publique pour rendre
l'avortement facile est permissible mais
notre population ne s'est pas laissé
influencer par cette campagne de presse
comme le démontre le nombre réduit des
avortements il est évident que l'église
respecte toute conscience individuelle
qui n'est responsable que devant dieu
mais cela étant dit il faut tout de même
revenir aux principes et il faut
rappeler ses principes
l'image la plus frappante que l'on
rapportera de seveso
c'est celle de ce mariage en pleine zone
contaminée
on se marie de nouveau à seveso malgré
tous les risques qui ont été évoqués
pour ceux qui y vivent et ce qu'ils
vivront plus tard le mal de seveso prend
de l'ampleur
le nuage polluants a franchi les cordons
de carabinier et les herses en travers
des routes autour de la première zone
interdite de cette région du nord de
l'italie
certains enfants des maladies de peau
d'autres des nouveau nés les
malformations encore inexpliquées rien
ne dit bien sûr qu'il ya une sorte de
rapport avec la dioxine
mais le mutisme du corps médical et des
autorités alimente la rumeur
en attendant que les experts donnent une
réponse s'ils le peuvent
les habitants de la région ont peur
surtout les futures mères seveso c'était
il ya neuf mois
victor vraiment sept mois se sont
écoulés et pourtant on reparle de seveso
comme si le nuage de dioxine venait à
peine de s'échapper de les iniques mesa
c'est que la dioxine s'est de nouveau
manifestée d'une façon particulièrement
cruel
sur le corps des enfants et des
adolescentes seveso car la dioxine c'est
aussi cette maladie de la peau cette
espèce d'acné juvénile qui n'en est pas
une et qu'on appelle clora cne parce
qu'elle serait dû au chlore contenu dans
le nuage toxique qui s'est abattue sur
seveso qui aura t-il
après la claque nez et puis comment se
fait-il que sept mois après la
catastrophe on ait trouvé dans les
écoles de seveso des doses de dioxine
dix sept fois supérieure au niveau
disons tolérable la réaction des
autorités locales a été immédiate
fermetures et des infections de toutes
les écoles mais il faut bien préciser
des infections et non pas des
contaminations puisque personne n'a
encore trouvé le moyen de détruire
complètement la dioxine
pourquoi n'at-on pas décelé la dioxine
plutôt qu'irresponsable le maire de
seveso se cache derrière les autorités
régionales
la région semble dire voyez le
gouvernement et le gouvernement mettent
en cause la fatalité pourquoi pas il est
vrai qu'à dioxine est aussi imprévisible
et désarmante qu'une fatalité
[Musique]
la dioxine qui en principe s'était
déposée dans la zone a est sorti et a
commencé à se propager dans un certain
rayon autour de la zone initiale nous
sommes en train de faire des
prélèvements sur le terrain et nous
avons des résultats déconcertant la
dioxine ne s'est pas propagée de façon
uniforme mais de façon désordonnée
les habitants de seveso ont peur comme
on peut avoir peur de quelque chose
qu'on ne connaît pas les premiers
enfants de la dioxine sont nés dans des
conditions normales
c'est vrai mais c'est à peine
réconfortant quand on pense qu'il y à
une quarantaine d'avortement
parce que les futures mères avaient peur
de mettre au monde des enfants anormaux
j'ajoute que les experts français que
j'ai consultés cet après-midi recommande
une certaine prudence avant tout
jugement définitif
la dioxine sous produit du trichlorure
phénol qui sert à fabriquer l'exacte
européenne qui est un désinfectant et un
désherbant on produisait du tricolore en
finale à milan pour le compte de la
société suisse ic mesa et se produire et
exporter ensuite en suisse et aux
etats-unis à l'accident à l'usiné il ya
sept mois
bien sûr vous vous en souvenez un nuage
de dioxine s'est répandu dans la nature
environ deux kilos dr halpern dioxine
égale poison il ya le poison cellulaire
c'est un produit qui est pratiquement
insoluble dans l'eau lorsqu'on
l'absorbent vont l'éliminent par les
voies naturelles
heureusement dans la majorité des cas il
ya quand même 20 % qui peuvent se
stocker dans le foie c'est un produit
qui atteint les cellules de la
reproduction et c'est un produit qui
diminue l'immunité c'est à dire qu'il
peut favoriser certaines maladies
infectieuses et qui peut favoriser les
cancers
en face dans l'ain a redit on ne sait
pas comment dissoudre la dioxine la
dessine absolument pas soluble dans
l'eau et la diction du produit chimique
extrêmement stabili est caractérisée par
une structure absolument symétrique
estomac voulait pas la détruire qui est
avec le fait avec la chaleur au moins
1200 degrés
et voilà un ouvrage d'environ 2 kg dans
le ciel de cette banlieue industrielle à
10 km au nord de milan il ya sept mois
et des retombées que l'on découvre les
unes après les autres jusqu'à ce matin
dépêche de l'agencé france presse daté
de milan on a découvert d'importantes
concentrations de dioxine de ce poison
dans les productions maraîchères de la
banlieue de milan
très précisément à nova milanaise et qui
se trouve ici qui n'est pourtant pas
nova milanese dans les zones les plus
dangereuses moyennement dangereuse et de
sécurité qui ont été déterminés par les
autorités italiennes alors premier point
un professeur cette contamination des
légumes
qu'en dites vous échoué il faut dire
d'abord que les analyses de la dioxine
d'un américain qui demande et
appareillages très puissant alors bien
on n'a pas pu faire une énorme nombre d'
analyse on a fait d'abord une ânerie
chaque 100 m dans toutes ses zones où on
avait vu que les nuages s'était déposée
n'a pu décéder la zone aa trucks
contamination où il ya plus qu et 25
milligrammes par mètre carré
la zone b où il ya une quantité assez
inférieure et la zone de sécurité ou la
dioxine faisant est aux limites de la
sensitivité c'est à dire 50 millionième
de millionième par mètre carré
de g à un gramme de dioxine ça peut
détruire un terrible ont bien animaux
par exemple
par exemple les animaux les plus
sensibles et les cobayes un grand des
dioxines peut tuer un million des kilos
des cobayes c'est à dire millions grâce
à ses 3 millions de cobayes
je suis beaucoup moins sensible et
l'homme on ne sait pas exactement enfin
une assimilation
un chien sens bien je vais alors il faut
d une quantité de 3 mille fois supérieur
mais quand même c'est une des plus
puissant poison existe là je vous
explique ici on pour expliquer le vent
qui soufflait par rafales à déposer le
noyage d'abord dans la zone à après il
ya une rechute dans les hommes les trois
zones b nuitées après peut-être dernière
phrase sport par le vent jusqu'à nova
milanese oui mais jusqu'à présent en
dehors de ces circuits pourrait que
l'analyse était fait mais regrette qu'il
y ait une totale jusqu'à présent des
5000 analyse et chaque analyse des
mondes plusieurs heures de techniciens
alors le laboratoire provincial
d'hygiène dit que certains échantillons
de légumes analysés présentent des
concentrations 500 fois supérieur à la
limite jugée tolérable donc ici que
va-t-on faire
si l'église ne sont pas consommables
faudra d'abord être sûr et répéter les
analyses par des contrôles croisent est
bon mais certainement il ya déjà eu en
bloc
déjà il ya dix jours d'un seulement une
seule chou-fleur était trouvée
contaminés il ya une block total de la
récolte l'autre compter de mars un
blocage total du marché des légumes d'un
arva milanese aussi dans les
municipalités à écouter les dernières
alertes signalé et nous en avons parlé
ici même il ya quelques jours concernés
de l'acné sur des enfants clora cne le
terme scientifique exa dans les écoles
de la région des analyses ont permis de
déterminer vous allez me dire comment
cette affection de la peau qui vient de
la dirisi sondés
professeur le père n'a mentionné latines
salsa s'élimine pas bien c'est presque
pas du tout éliminer par les urines
depuis qu'elle n'est pas insoluble dans
l'eau alors un petit bouton entre la pop
et au point where ressort elle donne une
dépression des mécanismes de défense
contre les bactéries
donc un petit infections dont il ya un
bouton alors dans les cas graves
il ya des centaines ou même des milliers
des boutons il faut dire que depuis que
certains médecins scolaires se sont
aperçus qu'il y avait des enfants avec
des boutons a examiné plus que 7000
enfants et permis 7000 infondées ces
communes de saison on n'a trouvé qu'un
411 cas d'acné plus ou moins grève
certains c'est seulement des cas
soupçonnés ça pourrait être une acné
vulgaire et ignorance et qu'il a qu'une
et ça se vérifie avec un temps de retard
de quelques mois après l'adoption alors
tous et 15 sont soumis à un contrôle
très strict et il faut vérifier qu est
ce qui est mal à rester dans les futurs
hits 411 cas constatés ce concept est
oui alors est ce que cette acné vous le
dites aussi peut être bénins est-ce
qu'il va disparaître ou est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres effets possibles prévisible les
enfants quand ils vivre avec leur duo hx
in
intérieurement pendant des années
tranquille tranquille dans quelques
semaines on peut pas être tranquille on
ne peut pas être tranquille parce que
dans les cas d'accidents précédent il ya
eu plusieurs accidents dont l'un de ces
chimique où il ya eu des fuites des
docks du dioxyde qu'ils ont contaminé
les ouvriers donnez nous quelques
exemples oui il ya eu des cas aux états
unis en hollande en allemagne en
tchécoslovaquie et en angleterre il ya
aussi le cas du vietnam amour pour
désherber des folies on a utilisé de la
dioxine et on ne sait pas ce qu'il ne
l'utilisé pas de la glycine ont utilisé
des désherbants qui contenait une frappe
et types de façades âgées dioxyde
mexique le vietnam
on a lancé six mille tonnes des produits
défoliant qui contenait un total de 150
kg de dioxine seveso c'est le premier
cas où la population autour des usines
et a été atteint exactement parce que
dans tous les autres cas l'établissement
chimiques étaient construits de façon
dans une façon qui ne permet tait peint
des fuites à l'extérieur un cas
d'explosion et là il ya eu fuite dans
l'atmosphère par une sorte de disque de
soupape draisine la soupape de sécurité
la disponibilité à péter se tait parce
qu'il ya une élévation de la température
qui était dû à beaucoup de cause
probablement des négligences télé une
installation mauvais état les mécanismes
de contrôle était c'est négliger toutes
les séries alors et une hausse de
température une hausse de tension la
soupape a fait son devoir est de sauter
est une émulsion il ne sort des aérosols
et sorties d'élèves alors liens et
notamment ses lecteurs un million il ya
une autre conséquence des enfants nés
après la précision
il y a eu sur un nombre de grossesses
constaté quatre malformations 4 sur 50
naissance de femmes de la région
on peut dire quelque chose oui c'est un
échantillon faible et les statisticiens
vous répondront qui n'est pas
significative ceci étant nous savons que
la dioxine peut donner des altérations
de l'enfant dans l'utérus de sa mère et
s'est prouvé chez l'animal et il est
vraisemblable que la dioxine est
directement responsable d'un certain
nombre de malformations faisant du savès
1 et il ya une grande polémique en
italie d'ailleurs lé gouvernement avait
autorisé les avortements - et seulement
40 éventuellement sous 3 140 femmes à
risque est de dire femme qui habitait
des maisons les plus pollués a été
permis et effectué ces quatre cas sous
50 sur le plan scientifique c'est pas
significatifs comme par exemple si un
sommet au bout de la rue au bout de cinq
ans voiture n'a compté quatre roses ça
veut pas dire qu'elle soit bien huilée
8% des runs alors là c'est trop petit
l'échantillon pour tirer des conclusions
en tout cas ça c'est suivi très
attentivement par les autorités à les
obtenir à conclure je voudrais vous
demander qu'est-ce qu'on peut
aujourd'hui tirer comme conclusion d'un
tel accident contrôle et bien sûr
vérifier les mégalithes
on voudrait que de l'exacte europen en
france on fabrique du tehrik leur finale
en france et les industries chimiques
sont des industries classées
le problème qui se pose en france comme
dans d'autres pays c'est que le
classement de ces industries effet
périodiquement et heureusement
l'industrie chimique progressent elles
s'améliorent et le résultat c'est que de
temps à autre une dioxine peut aussi
être vaporisé sur des populations en
france parce que on n'a pas eu le temps
d'adapter l'industrie à son
environnement
je crois que là il ya un problème
politique délibérément politique votre
avis quand je sors mon avis est que cet
accident on peut les empêcher a priori
avec des très bonnes lois et cette bonne
loi doit être faite en collaboration
avec les techniciens des scientifiques
et les lois doit donner seulement des
permissions à des procédés chimiques qui
donne des garanties et a posteriori il
faut un contrôle continu pour avoir un
contrôle continu
il faut des organes de contrôle public
qui sont qui doit avoir d excellents
laboratoire chimique des excédents de
laboratoire de pharmacologie et de
toxicologie et il faut en général
développe inconscient scientifique parce
que même parmi les ouvriers c'est très
important une certaine culture
scientifique
parmi les politiciens parmi les avocats
et les juristes qui font les lois c'est
très important
une conscience scientifique c'est
seulement sur la base d'un dossier
scientifique on pourra empêcher des
accidents de ce genre épargne constat
répété hélas après des accidents
pour conclure et pour donner une idée de
la gamme de problèmes qui se posent en
1966 aux pays bas il y a eu un accident
dans une usine 50 cas de d'acné de
clarac nez lusine a été détruite mais
comme on ne savait pas comment se
débarrasser d'une usine le béton le
matériel tout ce qu'ils étaient mais la
chimie les machines ont été transportés
par un bateau qui a été coulé au centre
de l'atlantique
merci messieurs hélas nous aurons
certainement à reparler de ce musée
souvenez-vous du journal télévisé du en
juillet 1976 c'est à dire il ya tout
juste aujourd'hui un an nous étions au
lendemain de la catastrophe de seveso en
fait nous ne savions pas alors qu'il
s'agissait vraiment d'une catastrophe
ce nuage de l' angoisse n'était pas
encore le nuage de la mort la mort elle
est venue après tout une ville maudite
près de milan et un ans après toujours
les mêmes fils de fer barbelés autour de
la zone contaminée
les habitants de ces maisons ont marqué
le triste anniversaire de la catastrophe
en manifestant en protestant d'apaiser
les fonctionnaires du gouvernement où
les fonctionnaires locaux ont été
incapables de prendre des décisions
précises les scientifiques se sont
trompés sur la gravité des effets de la
dioxine
les techniciens ont mené la
décontamination avec insouciance et ils
sont trop savoir ce qu'il fallait faire
le problème est le suivant pouvait-on
combattre efficacement une pollution
aussi grave et qu'il n'avait pas de
précédent
parce que la décontamination n'a pas eu
lieu car je dis que la contamine la
décontamination procédé à travers la
destruction de la dioxine la dioxine au
contraire a été porté à se déplacer a
été déplacé on a fait évacuer une zone
de 400 hectares 739 personnes ont dû
quitter leur maison
la dioxine ayant pénétré à 30
centimètres sous terre
il a fallu creuser au moins 50
centimètres la terre a été transporté
par camion et on a construit dans la
zone d'arles avait touché une véritable
montagne de terre contaminée
il a fallu envoyer les militaires et les
carabiniers pour empêcher les habitants
de la zone à d'aller dans leur maison
pour récupérer leurs affaires
personnelles
ça fait 40 ans que c'est polluer ici
alors vous croyez vraiment qu'il fallait
que je quitte ma maison pendant un an il
y à des hommes qui sont venus avec des
masques et puis alors ça a servi à
quelque chose
ils sont entrés dans ma maison ils ont
passé un coup d'aspirateur
ils ont utilisé une lessive pour laver
les murs et puis c'est tout pour eux ça
suffit pour moi non vous croyez qu'on
peut enlever la dioxine avec un
aspirateur peut-on détruire éliminer la
dioxine c'est tout le problème
et puis il a dit aussi ça se déplace on
a trouvé la dioxine à plusieurs
kilomètres de seveso dans des usines
dans des magasins dans des écoles
il est le vent les eaux souterraines les
personnes les oiseaux ou les chiens qui
vont boire dans la zone a et qui ensuite
reviennent dans les zones qui en
principe ne sont pas contaminés par la
dioxine
certains habitants de seveso veulent qui
croire malgré tout à la décontamination
et mettant pas demandé la dioxine
ce n'est pas un gaz mortel ça se trouve
dans la poussière
alors pourquoi est ce que ça ne
suffirait pas de passer l'aspirateur
si on a nettoyé à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur de la maison
si on a tout laver pourquoi est-ce que
je ne rentrerai pas chez moi en tout cas
c'est mon avis c'est mon impression
un an après la catastrophe on continue à
seveso a dénoncé l'incompétence ou le
laisser aller des autorités
c'est que beaucoup d'habitants ont vécu
des drames personnels il ya eu
l'apparition de l'acné cette espèce
d'acné juvénile déconcertante et peut
être dangereuse sur les visages de 250
enfants
l'année dernière quatre enfants sont nés
malformés il y en a eu 11 au cours des
six premiers mois de cette année
commence avec la dioxine pouvait
augmenter la proportion d'enfants
malformés un certain nombre de femmes
ont préféré avorté il y a eu 35
avortement reconnu et près de 80
avortements clandestins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui est très préoccupant c'est qu'il
ya une augmentation importante des
avortements spontanés
s'il ya des avortements spontanés c'est
que les femmes enceintes ont peur de
donner naissance à des enfants malformés
il ya toute une psychose aggravée par la
polémique entre les partisans et les
adversaires de l'avortement
comment éliminer la dioxine
faut-il construire un four et brûlé la
terre contaminée et les carcasses
d'animaux à 1200 degrés mais ce four ne
va-t-il pas produire lui aussi la
dioxine
que sait-on des effets de la dioxine sur
les futures générations
il ya tellement d'inconnues qu'il serait
vraiment trop facile d'accuser les
autorités italiennes
on a fait ce qu'on a pu avec plus ou
moins de conviction c'était le 10
juillet 1976 à seveso en italie 12h40 un
réacteur explose dans une usine de
produits chimiques appartenant à la
multinationale hoffman roche
givaudan le nuage épais et malodorants
qui se dégage est mortelle onze communes
proches de milan sont touchés par la
dioxine
un vrai poison l'effeuillage tombe les
chiens les moutons moeurs 44 enfants
sont marqués à jamais l' angoisse vient
de commencer pour 80 mille habitants
presque trois ans après les polémiques
continue le nombre d'enfants mort nés
malformés augmenté dans sept régions
est ce dû à la dioxine une enquête de
jean jacques dufour derrière cette
pancarte la dioxine un mal une présence
invisible depuis des mois et des mois
ces ouvriers travaillent constamment
pour la faire disparaître la dioxine une
molécule qui s'accrochent si fort à ce
qu'elle touche que tous ces camions
devront être détruits après cette
piscine a été démolie comme l'ont déjà
été de nombreuses maisons pour éviter
qu'il reste des traces de contamination
il a fallu tué 81 mille animaux
domestiques et les immerger dans de la
soude caustique avant de les enterrer
neuf mille mètres cubes de végétation
ont déjà été ensevelis seveso est devenu
un vaste domaine d'expérimentation en
plein air où étudient institut de
zoologie d'anthropologie de pathologies
humaines et c'est là bas derrière ces
arbres on a même planté des légumes pour
voir en attendant les résultats de ses
observations scientifiques chaque jour
on continue aussi un jardinage un peu
spécial chaque jour ces sommes doivent
jeter tous leurs équipements
un travail qui depuis le début s'est
effectuée comme la marche d'un aveugle à
tâtons ils sont chefs d'état
ce défi coltart depuis le début il y a
eu des difficultés techniques dans la
mesure où on a toujours été isolé face à
ce problème
jamais avant ces vaisseaux il y avait eu
de précédent aussi vaste le coût des
dégâts dont seuls ces hautes palissades
proche de l'autoroute témoigne a été
chiffré à 600 millions de francs
sans comptabiliser bien sûr les effets
secondaires qu'on ne connaît pas
officiellement en 77 il y avait eu 38
enfants malformés en 60 18 53 certains
disent même 142 alors le nombre plus
grand de malformations chez les nouveau
nés est il dû à la dioxine
il n'est pas possible de l'affirmer mais
il n'est pas possible d'affirmer le
contraire non plus ce qu'on sait c'est
que ce produit injecté à des femelles de
hamster aidera à des effets tératogènes
les petits naissent anormaux cette
question pose le problème de la toxicité
génétique de certains produits
car si avant ces vaisseaux des accidents
avaient permis d'évaluer le danger
considérable de ce produit il n'avait
pas encore été possible de savoir
précisément quels étaient les risques
encourus pas
les femmes et leur descendance poursuivi
les scientifiques avaient défini il
n'est pas possible d'établir
scientifiquement si ces malformations
sont imputables ou non à la dioxine
mais cela ne permet quand même pas
d'être optimiste maintenant il faut
ouvrir le débat pour essayer de prévenir
les dangers ou les dégâts éventuels qui
pourraient altérer l'état de santé des
adultes ou davantage encore des
nouveau-nés talent comment se comportent
psychologiquement les femmes quand le
nuage a explosé il ya eu un sentiment
général de peur et à ce moment là plus
personne ne voulait avoir d'enfant en ni
les allaiter puis tout est rentré dans
l'ordre parce que finalement les gens
pensent maintenant la dioxine est là et
il faut faire avec et us à la
résignation optimiste yvonne
qu'ancelotti est renforcée elle vient
d'accoucher d'un petit fabio cinq jours
parfaitement sain pourtant durant neuf
mois c'est avec angoisse qu elle a subi
toutes les analyses préventives
nécessaires depuis quinze jours à nuages
chimique s'est posée ici dans ce climat
de tâtonnement expérimental vivent les
habitants des onze communes concernées
des habitants qui dans leur majorité
sont exaspérés par cette histoire sans
certitude dans laquelle il joue le rôle
de cobaye on en a marre on ne connaît
pas la vérité dioxyde with you xing non
naissance normal les sens ça normal
on verra bien avec nos yeux si la
situation empire on apprend des vidéos
exaspération bien compréhensible un jour
la dioxine a officiellement disparu le
lendemain on retrouve des traces de sa
présence dans cette école situés hors
des zones touchées jaune à propos
desquels d'ailleurs la polémique
maintenant politique rebondi la carte
établissant dans les premiers jours
l'étendue des dégâts auraient été
réduite par le président démocrate
chrétien de la commission régionale de
lombardie
c'est du moins ce qu'affirme madame
laura conti du parti communiste le
problème et c'est dommage qu'on l'a pas
fait
tout de suite à présent nous ne sont pas
à même de dire à la population si il y à
un danger pour le bébé mais elle se
pensait pas que les gens de ces
vaisseaux minimise un peu la situation
parce qu'on a l'impression que ça les
dérange pas finalement ils vivent avec
oui il n'y avait de fait une angoisse
ce écologie et le dossier
c'est évidemment la région est riche les
intérêts économiques sont grands et pour
la plupart des habitants artisans qui
travaillent le bois ce genre d'histoire
n'est pas bonne pour le commerce juste
après le drame certains industriels
étrangers ont refusé d'acheter leurs
marchandises
et puis la dioxine est invisible et on
croit difficilement aux effets de ce
qu'on ne voit pas d'ailleurs sur les
quelque 200 familles évacuées de la zone
à la plus contaminée
on ne compte qu'une ou deux personnes
ayant refusé de revenir les autres ont
repris leurs habitudes
imperturbable comme ces vieux qui font
une partie de ce qu pas dans ce café qui
vient de rouvrir après avoir été fermée
un an
moi personnellement je ne connais pas
d'enfants nés avec des malformations
vous savez nous on est retraité on vient
jouer aux cartes
le 10 juillet 1976 s'était échappé à
cette heure même 12h45 exactement un
nuage de fumée rose nuage de fumée rose
qui allait changer et l'histoire de
cette ville et de ses habitants
allez sans poils être entraînés dans
cette direction qui sut ma main allait
s'abattre sur les maisons de ses
quartiers de seveso qui se trouve au
delà de cette barrière symbolique de
plastique jaune qui aujourd'hui c'est
par la vie où je me trouve et sept
villes fantomatiques où qu'ils se
trouvent derrière cette barrière jaune
ces maisons sont abandonnées plus de
mille personnes ont été évacuées sur les
maisons sur les arbres dans la nature
sur la terre dans la terre c'est déposer
une fine couche de dioxine qui depuis
empêchent les habitants de retrouver
leur maison
à travers cette zone contaminée personne
personne ne peut rentrer sauf tous les
jours une équipe d'ouvriers qui tous les
matins se déguise un peu à la manière
des martiens pour entrer et pourra
battre l'ensemble des maisons l'ensemble
des arbres raser la terre la gratter sur
plus de 30 centimètres pour essayer de
rendre ce quartier de seveso à la vie
c'est à l'intérieur de ce quartier
interdit à la vie que martine allain
regnault une équipe des envoyés spéciaux
d'antenne 2 ont réussi à pénétrer je
vous propose tout de suite
de voir leurs témoignages
pull à col roulé chaussettes caleçon
combinaison une paire de gants blancs
plus une paire de gants de caoutchouc un
masque plus un filtre chaque matin une
vingtaine d'ouvriers arrive à 7 heures
sur le chantier de la zone à de seveso
reçoivent le même paquetage et se
soumettre au même rituel chaque jour ils
doivent se dépouiller entièrement de
leurs vêtements de ville et se couvrir
d'un équipement étanche encombrants trop
chaud l'été pas assez chaud l'hiver pour
aller travailler dans la zone fortement
contaminé en dioxine
chaque jour cet équipement qui coûte
plus de 400 francs sera jetée à
l'exception du masque qui est personnel
et décontaminer au retour et des bottes
qui seront on le verra tout à l'heure
scrupuleusement laver et serviront dix
fois au maximum
chaque jour tels des martiens ou des
survivants d'une troisième guerre
mondiale
ils vont durant quatre heures exécuter
une série de gestes très ordinaire dans
une situation extraordinaire
dès que l'on à franchi la barrière jaune
tous sans exception est à l'intérieur de
la zone considéré comme empoisonné c'est
à dire contaminés par la dioxine à une
dose suffisamment dangereuse pour être
coupés du reste du monde est totalement
détruit arbres et maisons comprise à
partir d'ici la dioxine règne encore en
maître sur le sol et dans le sol à la
même dose qu'il y a cinq ans et il faut
l'en déloger en sachant que tout
mouvement tout ébranlement toute
circulation tout coup de vent peut la
faire voler la disséminer c'est pourquoi
la moitié des ouvriers passent leur
temps de travail à tout arrosé tout le
temps
ici tout est à faire pour bonifier cette
zone
c'est ainsi que les italiens définissent
l'opération il faut détruire en menus
morceaux tous ceux qui a reçu de la
dioxine pousse dans la terre dioxines et
il faut aussi enlever au moins 30
centimètres de terre sur 53 hectares
cinq ans après l'accident les
prélèvements le prouve la dioxine est
toujours là insoluble elle s'est collé
au sol et elle y reste accroché comme du
mazout sur un rocher pour l'en déloger
il faut enlever avec elle son support
arbres maison terre
c'est ce travail pénible que ces
ouvriers mélange de titan et de fourmies
accomplissent depuis plusieurs années
nous avons assisté à une séance de
défrichage de quelques mètres carrés
on travaille aux bulldozers mais aussi à
la serpette centimètre par centimètre
chaque plante chaque branche chaque trou
doivent être abattus et déchiqueté
ce tronc d'arbre par exemple doit se
terminer par un petit tas de copeaux
rien n'est simple ici le terrain est
accidenté et les arbres solidement
enracinée il est difficile de
communiquer de recevoir des ordres
parfois il faut se parler comme les
sourds muets
ces maisons sont à détruire elle aussi
en menus débris ailleurs on a pu les
laver au détergent et les rendre leurs
habitants ici c'est trop risqué pour
toujours d'y habiter et d'y cultiver
fleurs et fruits
la végétation a une apparence normale
mais les plus belles choses sont
empoisonnés alors dans le programme
tout sera réduit en morceaux sachez que
l'opération global d'assainissement et
d'indemnisation de seveso coûtera plus
de 100 milliards de centimes
un exemple aux passagers cette grue se
trouvait là au moment de l'accident à
détruire quant aux enjeux que l'on
utilise pour la bonification
il était propre départ ils sont devenus
contaminés alors ils n'ont plus le droit
de sortir de la zone un garage de
fortune permet de les réparer et de
récurer les citernes sur place
au bout de quatre heures maximum les
ouvriers arrête ce travail pénible
choisi en bonne santé après un examen
médical très bien payé il ne reste
jamais cependant très longtemps affecté
à cette zone en raison du travail
pénible et des risques potentiels de la
dioxine
à la fin de chaque matinée ils se
déshabillent des pieds à la tête se
douche shampoing compris leurs vêtements
seront jetés dans des sacs en plastique
qui s'accumulent eux aussi dans la zone
contaminée
reste l'avenir c'est à la frontière
entre la route nationale et cette zone
maudite que poubelles animaux copeaux
des brit air bref tout ce qui est
suspect d'être contaminé sera enfoui
définitivement dans un immense trou de
90 mille mètres carrés transformer en un
cimetière étanche de la dioxine
alors là nous avons un point de vue
technique qui peut dans une certaine
mesure rassurer les habitants de seveso
mais j'ai eu l'occasion de parler avec
un certain nombre de familles à seveso
et il ne s'agit ni d'optimisme dini de
pessimisme mais plutôt d'une certaine
résignation
en tout cas nous avons eu l'occasion de
rencontrer le boulanger qui de c'est les
autres qui est retourné à la zone a est
aussi le curé de saison il ya exactement
cinq ans complètement isolée du reste du
monde
son nom scapa tin tin tin quoi l'odeur
est active je me suis précipité dans la
cave
il y avait une odeur insupportable et
j'ai eu peur je me suis réfugié dans la
cave et au bout de quelques temps loder
a disparu le boulanger de la zone a est
revenu c'est à dire que lui et sa
famille habitait dans la zone qui était
la plus touchée par la dioxine
ils ont été évacués ils ont vécu dans un
hôtel de seveso pendant un an et demi
et puis ils sont revenus je n'ai pas eu
peur de revenir ici c'est à dire que
j'ai cinq enfants à nourrir
fallait bien retourner au travail
on n'avait plus d'argent vous avez été
indemnisé par la givaudan on n'a pas
donné ce que j'ai demandé qu'on m'a
donné 50% même pas le vrai préjudice on
ne me l'a jamais payé etc ok nous ne
sommes plus comme avant nous sommes
devenus nerveux
ma fille renat quand elle doit manger
quelque chose elle me demande toujours
mais dit maman il n'y a pas de dioxyde
là dedans c'est bien nettoyer tu es sûr
qu'il n'ya pas de jokes il l a toujours
peur
dans cette région de seveso où il ya 70
% de pratiquants donne giuseppe est sans
doute celui qui connaît le mieux les
états d'âme des habitants il est curé de
seveso depuis 16 ans 11 ans avant et
cinq ans après la catastrophe
et emmène tâtonnons que le nombre des
mariages a diminué de moitié mon dieu oh
c'est plus ou moins comme avant ce n'est
pas que les gens ont peur de se marier
maintenant famille
non non ce mari ont fondé des familles
comme avant ce genre de préoccupations
n'existe pas les naissances pour les
naissances c'est normal il ya une baisse
de la natalité mais c'est un phénomène
qui est vrai dans toute l'italie
et puis les enfants qui naissent on
normaux les gens voudraient qu'on ne
déforme pas l'effet qu'on s'en tienne à
la réalité
les gens sont conscients du danger qui
existait mais il ne faut pas exagérer on
a parfois présentés seveso comme un
village détruit ce qui tout de même
contraire à la réalité et ce sont
surtout les conséquences de cette
catastrophe écologique sur la santé des
personnes exposées qui pose encore un
certain nombre de questions dont la
question essentielle quel est le
véritable danger que représente cette
dioxine pour les êtres humains
à long terme on aimerait bien sûr après
l'accident de reims être tout à fait
rassuré mais de fait l'exemple de seveso
n'apporte pas de réponse définitive sur
ce point depuis neuf ans l'hôpital de
desio localité voisine de seveso est
chargé du suivi médical des personnes
exposées à des degrés divers au nuage
toxique
au départ on a procédé à un contrôle
systématique dans un rayon de 10
kilomètres autour de l'usiné
onze villages 220 mille habitants
aujourd'hui toutes ces fiches médicales
sont consignés dans cet ordinateur des
archives électroniques grâce auquel il
est possible à tout moment d'observer
l'évolution de l'état de santé de tel ou
tel individu
cependant avec le temps le champ
d'investigation s'est considérablement
réduit aujourd'hui les médecins de
l'hôpital de desio ne contrôle plus que
les personnes à risque
elles sont au nombre de 170 en grande
majorité il s'agit
ouvriers qui ont travaillé sur la zone
interdite mais on y trouve également les
enfants et les quelques adultes qui à
l'époque avait été victime de clarac
nique dans leur cas les examens sont
réguliers et se poursuivront jusqu'en
chaque année ces 170 personnes
contaminés par la dioxine subisse un
check up complet et des contrôles
spécifiques et la toxicologie examens
pulmonaires mais surtout analyses de
sang et d'urines analyse qui permettent
de détecter les anomalies de l'organisme
jusqu'à présent le laboratoire de
l'hôpital l'un des mieux équipées
d'italie depuis la catastrophe de seveso
n'a constaté aucune altération de l'état
de santé de ses patients à seveso neuf
ans après on ne meurt pas plus
qu'ailleurs et le nombre des cancers ni
pas plus important c'est un premier
constat mais prudence
il est encore impossible aujourd'hui de
prévoir à long terme les effets de la
dioxine
ces effets pervers on les étudie dans un
autre laboratoire celui de l'institut de
recherche pharmacologique de milan
l'institut mario negri dirigée par le
professeur caratini l'un des
spécialistes mondiaux de la toxicologie
ici en a créé depuis l'explosion de
seveso une cellule de crise
cet appareil le spectromètre de masse
est capable de détecter la plus infimes
traces de dioxine dans notre
environnement et dans l'organisme
jusqu au milliardième de mg dans ce
laboratoire
on a également réalisé des expériences
de toxicité sur les animaux résultat 2
kg de dioxine peuvent tuer 50 milliards
de cobaye
il s'agit bien sûr d'une statistique
mais cela démontre que la substance est
très dangereux par discussion sur le
fait qu'il s'agit de matériel toxiques
il y à une discussion sur le fait que ou
pas tous les espèces sont également
sensibles par exemple le chêne semble
être moins sensible que le rat ou le
cobaye mais la cje et relativement
sensible et pas l'homme l'homme on ne
sépare car on n'a pas encore de données
définitives sur l'exposition de l'oma
dans les différents accidents qui sont
arrivés et on n'a pas encore tous leurs
données car comme j'ai dit il faut
attendre certes inférieur de temps
effets sur l'organisme mais également
sur le terrain dans le cas de seveso
l'institut mario negri a procédé à plus
de 5000 analyses afin d'évaluer la
diffusion et degré de concentration de
ce puissant toxiques sur l'environnement
c'est à partir de ces résultats que l'on
a pu mesurer la réelle ampleur de la
catastrophe et déterminer le type de
dioxine contenue dans le nuage de
licques mesa autre constat chaque
incident de ce genre peut engendrer une
substance différentes reims n'échappe
pas à la règle à rien s'il ya surtout de
bibelots furane pour les clauses ouvert
il faut dire par exemple que la traque
titre accor dibango furane et moins
toxiques
aussi selon notre termine à sion que la
tétralogie basse au dioxyde donc il ya
une différence à qualitative dans des
composants chimiques qui sont en jeu
en ce qui concerne les composants
quantitative
j'ai l'impression que il y a des
quantités qui sont comparables à la zone
contaminée de ce vaisseau c'est à dire
que vous êtes tout à fait d'accord avec
les analyses du processeur rap oui je
pense que c'est très difficile de
discuter les analyses de monsieur rap
qui est un de compétent internationale
que lille il nous il nous a aidés aussi
pour la fin de saison donc je pense que
lui il est
selon le chercheur qui a les moyens
meilleur danalyse de ce type de
contaminer l'autre différence encore
entre seveso et rennes c'est que à
seveso made you seen est arrivé par
l'extérieur sur les maisons et dans les
maisons
c'était juillet donc il y avait les
ouvert les fenêtres étaient pourtant
ouvert et tout le matériel entrées
tandis que ares le matériel et un prêt
par l'intérieur ça j'y pense devrait
simplifier le problème de la
décontamination par rapport à la sphère
de ce réseau la catastrophe écologique
de seveso doit nous permettre de tirer
au moins deux enseignements d'abord
qu'il ne faut pas jouer aux apprentis
sorciers avec une substance dont on ne
mesure pas les conséquences
ensuite il faut agir avec une extrême
prudence après l'incident les
importantes mesures de sécurité prises
par les italiens ont parfois été jugée
excessive mais c'est peut-être grâce à
ses infinies précautions qu'on a évité
le pire
[Musique]